And everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Connors. I just want to go over with you
2026 now really what our clinic stands for
what we do with our clinic and
How we try to minister to people that come to us
We are clinic we do care for people
Mainly that have cancer diagnosis. We don't diagnose cancer, but we're here to take care of people from an alternative perspective
as best as we possibly can
Prayed for wisdom of God for us to be able to help care for our patients
All of it's done at a distance
So we have a clinic that some people do come to for different therapies and for testing
99% of the time everything's done at a distance. So we do distance testing
Distance cheek swab testing to get to a protocol and different lab testing to figure out
Reasons why and dealing with that reason why we'll touch on that as we go here
We are really a ministry. That's what we look at being as best as we possibly can
That doesn't mean that we can just do things for free
We still have bills to pay and things
But we do offer a lot of free information
So there's tons of blog posts. I think over 2,000 blog posts most of them have videos
We have a video site with several thousand videos. So I understand when people are from a
Financial perspective can't really afford to do alternative care
Well, we have more free information than any clinic on the planet. I'm pretty sure of that
I haven't measured it, but I'm pretty sure of that
Also, you can look at a book, you know, I have multiple books, but two cancer books one large
600 page cancer book that we are just updating as I speak right now to our latest edition for
2026 and many people have used that alone to help make decisions about protocol and taking care of their cancer
We also have different courses. I made courses for Lyme disease because I had Lyme disease multiple times and using the
RIF technology for cancer
RIF technology works fantastic for Lyme disease. So over the years, I've taken care of thousands of Lyme patients
many many of them getting a RIF machine using the RIF for Lyme disease and
I have specialized in autoimmune disease. So my course on autoimmune disease
I highly recommend for non-cancer patients
I
Very big into genetics. We do genetics on all our cancer patients
So I've created a read your genes course with tons of videos and how to understand your genetics
I've written a book the seven phases of detoxification and then I turn it into a course to understand
How to do toxify in the best ways to go about it so that you don't make yourself sicker and
Then the frequency healing course because we're so into using RIF technology
That's what got me into taking care of cancer patients from the very beginning bake back in the late 90s
gosh, we've been doing this
going on
Almost 30 years. So it
RIF technology is a big piece of our clinic helping people with cancer patients helping people with a cancer diagnosis and helping people with all sorts of
Like Lyme and different things. RIF technology is just priceless and our frequency healing course goes over
tons of information on how to best use a
RIF machine and then our basic flagship the stop fighting cancer and start treating the cause
That was my original book from 2012 that was a huge hit and hour on that
I think the fourth edition is the new one that's coming out this year
And I turned that into a course
So stop fighting cancer and start treating the cause is our key
So most people that have cancer come on with our cancer plan. That's our full private membership
We have our it has its own website that you can only access as a full private member
There's tons of benefits to that website. We do a weekly zoom call
Where members can get on and ask questions
We go chat back and forth they can ask live questions they can post questions and then those are
Recorded those zoom calls are recorded so that you can watch it afterwards
And access the information if you had questions and you weren't able to get on
On that full membership, it has other different protocols. It has tons more information that we don't give to the public
That's where most of our patients really start
They do our full cancer plan
Included in that cancer plan is all the testing
However, I said cause is huge for us if you're not digging to find the cause of your cancer
You know, you can do chemo you can do
You know radiation you can do immunotherapy you can do surgery and you could knock down the cancer
But if you're not getting to the cause that's those are the cases where
You know what quote-a-quote comes back with the vengeance while it was never really gone
You'd never really dealt with the reason why
So we need to do testing to really dig to find out that reason why it's never gonna be perfect
But we're gonna get some really good ideas on what to deal with different toxicities. We need to deal with
Different bio toxins. We need to deal with those are main causes of cancer that we have to address
We deal our old cheeks walked swab testing that's in house testing where we put together your initial protocol
Then we get your toxicity test back and your genetic test back and we can tweak that protocol
That's gonna be extremely unique to you
So that's part of our full cancer plan and of course you get a programmed right machine
I have done all the programming for it. It'll be programmed to your diagnosis
You'll be using that every night
And you could use it during the day when you're sitting around relaxing, but you're definitely gonna be using that every night
And then you're gonna be following the dietary protocol that we're gonna put together for you
excuse me
and and um
The nutritional protocol that we're gonna put together for you
We need to hit this. It is many different ways as possible and many people ask
Well, what if I still want to do chemo? Well, that's just fine
You can still do nothing we're going to recommend is gonna interfere with chemotherapy or radiation or surgery
Will work through that some people still want to follow standards of care. That's great
Some people have exhausted that and that's okay too. We just need to hit this as best as we possibly can
And like I said asking that question why is the key to us at least
Always looking to uncover the cause. That's why I named the book stop fighting cancer and start treating the cause
We need to get to that cause and
That's you're gonna be your best results regardless of whether you're doing standards of care or not
Now we believe that God is ultimately your healer and
When patients come on with us. We ask them to continue to pray for wisdom for us
So that we are gonna be best equipped to be able to give you that wisdom
So we know that God is your healer. We trusted him regardless of whether you decide to start with us or not or just use our website for information
That's great. We want to be praying for you. We know that that is our greatest strength
So all of this this is gonna be a little
Cap of what we do know that we're gonna be praying for you
And we just wish you the best. Thanks